[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin ihn allen einen schönen
guten Abend mir im Studio ist wieder
Christin Otto später unter anderem mit
dem DFB Pokal voller Emotionen guten
Abend ja heute sind wieder starke Nerven
gefragt schauen wir gemeinsam auf die
Themen Chaostage bei der Bahn wegen des
Warnstreiks der logführer fahren die
Züge bis morgen Abend nur im Notfahrplan
im Süden wegen Schnee teilweise gar
nicht Krankschreibung per Telefon ab
sofort müssen Patienten mit leichten
Symptomen nicht mehr in die Praxis
kommen das hilft auch bei der aktuellen
Erkältungswelle und Annäherung unter
Erzfeinden nach Jahren des Streits
wollen Griechenland und die Türkei ihre
Beziehungen
verbessern wieder ein warnstreig der
Lockführer wieder fährt so gut wie
nichts zumindest im Süden wo noch immer
die Folgen des Schneechaos nachwirken
seit einer Stunde wird der Güterverkehr
bestreigt ab 22 Uhr dann der
Personenverkehr es sind harte Zeiten für
bahnfahrende aber
immerhin ist es für dieses Jahr der
letzte loogführerstreik über den
Ausstand und die Reaktionen Hansjürgen
Piel Rangierbahnhof Maschen bei Hamburg
seit einer Stunde bewegt sich hier nur
noch wenig Streik der
lockführergewerkschaft seit 18 Uhr will
die den DB Güterverkehr und ab 22 Uhr
auch den Personenverkehr deutschlandweit
lahmlegen bis in den späten Freitagabend
hinein der Streik ist unverhältnismäßig
er ist unnötig und ist vor allem
unverantwortlich man hätte ja auch
dieabstimmung abwarten können so aber
werden wiederum ausgerechnet in
Adventszeit die Fahrpläne von Millionen
die Reisepläne von Millionen Fahrgästen
durcheinander gebracht die Tarifrunde
ist festgefahren vor drei Wochen hatte
die GDL das Scheitern der Verhandlungen
erklärt und eine Urabstimmung über
unbefristete Streiks gestartet
Knackpunkt ist vor allem die geforderte
35 Stunden Woche für Schichtarbeiter bei
vollem Lohnausgleich dieses Thema sieht
der Bahnvorstand als nicht verhandelbar
es fehle an zusätzlichem Personal mit
dem Warnstreik will die Gewerkschaft die
Bahn jetzt dazu zwingen auch darüber zu
sprechen und Verständnis bei Bahnkunden
ich habe Verständnis gehabt aber
irgendwie ist jetzt die Geduld am Ende
ich finde jetzt ist es ein bisschen
überzogen und in dieser Zeit ist es
natürlich doch für sehr viele sehr
schwierig geworden immerhin nach
gdlangaben sollen die Weihnachtstage und
der jahreswechselstreik frei bleiben es
ist für dieses Jahr der letzte
Arbeitskampf und wir werden am 19
Dezember die uhabstimmung auszählen und
dann werden wir bis zum 7 Januar keine
Arbeitskämpfe durchführen aber
anschließend wird's länger und heftiger
sein die Deutsche Bahn will versuchen
morgen einen Notfahrplan
aufrechtzalten dann wollen wir
Nachfragen bei Stefanie Hein für uns am
Berliner Hauptbahnhof Stefanie wie viel
stillstand gibt es und wie hat man sich
darauf eingestellt
ja die Bahn hat ja heute den ganzen Tag
schon gewart man sollte wann immer man
kann heute so früh wie möglich fahren
und im besten Falle schon 18 Uhr da sein
wo man hin will denn schon jetzt ist
klar es gibt verschiedene züge bei denen
jetzt schon ganz sicher ist dass sie ihr
Ziel nicht erreichen dass sie statt nach
Frankfurt nur noch nach Kassel oder
statt nach Bonn nur noch bis Hanover
kommen die Bahn will 20% ihres
Fernverkehrs aufrechterhalten
und will die Züge die dafür dann geplant
sind jetzt auch nach und nach in die
Informationsnetze ein einspeisen und sie
sagen aber auch jetzt schon in diesen
20% aller Fernverkehrszüge da werden
längst nicht alle Menschen mitkommen die
das tatsächlich haben wollen das wird
mit Sicherheit nicht einfach wie das
direkt für den Regionalverkehr aussehen
wird das ist noch nicht klar ganz
besonders in Bayern da ist es ja sowieso
noch schwierig und am Freitag wird
gestreigt am sonneren werden die Züge
also langsam wieder dahingestellt wo sie
hin soll und am Sonntag ist dann der
Fahrplanwechsel wer dieses Wochenende
unterwegs sein will der braucht
wahrscheinlich starke Nerven vielen Dank
Stefanie nach Berlin jetzt zum
Haushaltsstreit da hat die SPD
Bundestagsfraktion jetzt eingestanden
dass der Haushalt 2024 nicht mehr bis
zum Jahresende verabschiedet werden kann
man hofft aber auf eine gemeinsame
Verabredung in der Koalition auch noch
vor Weihnachten das sagte
Generalsekretär küet beim Presserundgang
vor dem SPD Parteitag der Morgen beginnt
man wolle aufs Tempo drücken aber keine
schlechten Kompromisse eingehen wir
gehen zu Diana Zimmermann nach Berlin
Diana also die SPD macht öffentlich
womit die meisten schon rechneten was
bedeutet das
jetzt es bedeutet dass das Jahr 2024 mit
einem vorläufigen Haushalt starten wird
einfach weil es jetzt unmöglich ist noch
alle parlamentarischen Schritte zu gehen
vor Ende des Jahres für einen regulären
Haushalt ein vorläufiger Haushalt ist
erstmal kein DRAM alle notwendigen
Ausgaben werden weiter getätigt alle
Sozialleistungen werden gezahlt aber es
bedeutet eben Unsicherheit vor allen
Dingen für Unternehmen die auf Kredite
oder fördersommen vom Bund angewiesen
sind dramatisch ist der Ansehensverlust
der Ampel die drei Koalitionsspitzen
können sich offensichtlich immer noch
nicht einigen wie sie das Geld
auftreiben wollen sie reden weiter über
Steuererhöhungen über Einsparungen und
so hören wir auch über die Erklärung
einer Notfallsituation Begründung der
Krieg in der Ukraine morgen Nachmittag
wird hier verhandelt am Samstag muss
dann der Kanzler seine Grundsatzrede auf
dem SPD Parteitag halten und da wird
angesichts dieser Krise und der
schlechten Umfragewerte der SPD der
Jubel wohl nicht besonders groß sein
Diana vielen Dank für deine
Einschätzung aktuell gibt es einen
relativ hohen Krankenstand in
Deutschland da ist es für viele eine
gute Nachricht dass eine Krankschreibung
wie in schlimmen coronajahren künftig
auch wieder telefonisch möglich ist so
wurde das heute beschlossen warum Ärzte
das Begrüßen Arbeitgeber er nicht und
was generell beachtet werden sollte dazu
Roman lesk war bei Wolfgang Kreischer
geben sich derzeit die Patienten die
Klinke in die Hand viele hat die
aktuelle Infektionswelle erwischt in der
Pandemie war die Krankschreibung
telefonisch möglich seit dem Frühjahr
aber müssen die Patienten wieder in die
Praxis sehr zum Ärger des
Hausarztes Sprechzimmer wurden wieder
voller die Arbeitsbelastung wurde größer
und die Effektivität hat abgenommen weil
es geht ja nur darum solche Menschen
dann auch krank zu schreiben und aus dem
Verkehr zu ziehen die Ärzteverbände
machten Druck um die telefonische
Krankschreibung dauerhaft einzuführen
mit Erfolg heute gab der Gemeinsame
Bundesausschuss die Details bekannt
maximal 5 Tage dürfen Mediziner per
Telefon krankchreiben beim Patienten
dürfen keine schweren Symptome vorliegen
und er muss in der Praxis bereits
bekannt sein eine Verpflichtung des
Arztes besteht allerdings nicht es gibt
kein Anrecht der Patientinnen der
Patienten auf eine telefonische
Krankschreibung sondern das ist die
Entscheidung der Ärztin des Arztes der
Arbeitgeberverband kritisiert die
Neuregelung die zu mehr
Krankschreibungen führen könnte dass die
telefonische Krankschreibung missbraucht
werde glauben ärzteevertreter allerdings
nicht die Menschen können sich jetzt
nicht von einer Praxis zu anderen
durchtelefonieren sind soll sie müssen
zu ihrer hausärztlichen Praxis gehen und
da ist durch die Bindung natürlich auch
diese Form von Kontrolle da die sich die
Arbeitgeber an der Stelle wünschen so
sind also Ärzte wie Wolfgang Kreischer
künftig gefordert Vorbehalte gegenüber
der telefonischen Krankschreibung
auszuräumen mal angenommen Sie wollen
ein Auto auf Raten kaufen oder eine
Wohnung mieten dann wird die andere
Seite mit Sicherheit ihren Schufascore
abfragen um zu sehen wie kreditwürtig
sie sind schufer ja das ist eine private
auskunftteil das Unternehmen das sammelt
Daten über nahzu jeder Mann etwa zu
Bankkonten Leasingverträgen oder
Krediten und er rechnet dann daraus
automatisch einen zuverlässigkeitsscore
von 0 bis 100%. und jetzt eine
entscheidende Frage dürfen Banken oder
Vermieter allein aufgrund dieses Scores
Kunden ablehnen nein sagte heute der
Europäische Gerichtshof Christop
Schneider wer den Stromanbieter wechseln
oder einen Handyvertrag abschließen will
der kommt an der schufahmeist nicht
vorbei sie hat Daten von rund 68
Millionen Menschen mit diesen Daten wird
durch mathematisch statistische
Verfahren ein Wahrscheinlichkeitswert
ermittelt der sogenannte scorwert dieser
bestimmt wie kreditwürdig man ist
wichtig z.B für Banken doch der
Europäische Gerichtshof entscheidet
dieser scorwert verstößt gegen die
datenschutzgrundverordnung das Scoring
ist nach der datenschutzgrundverordnung
grundsätzlich verboten sofern der
Abschluss eines Vertrags wie etwa die
Gewährung eines Kredits maßgeblich von
dem scorwert abhängt die kann mit der
Entscheidung Leben sieht sich richtig
aufgestellt die ganz
überragende Mehrheit unserer Kunden hat
uns rückgemeldet dass der schuferscore
zwar wichtig ist se wir eben nicht
maßgeblich für die Kreditentscheidung
eine Möglichkeit das zu überprüfen hat
der Verbraucher allerdings nicht
grundsätzlich ist es verboten die
Entscheidung über die Vergabe eines
Kredits oder Vertrags maßgeblich vom
Schufascore abhängig zu machen aber von
diesem Grundsatz kann es Ausnahmen geben
und genau das müssen nun deutsche
Gerichte prüfen das heißt die Richtung
auf europäischer Ebene ist klar sie muss
jetzt aber noch von deutschen Gerichten
umgesetzt werden verbraucherschützer
fordern schon lange mehr Klarheit von
der Schufa hoffen auf ein neues Gesetz
aus unserer Sicht wäre es wichtig dass
dieses Urteil jetzt für den Gesetzgeber
der Anstoß ist neue transparenzregelung
auf den Weg zu bringen nach der
Luxemburger Entscheidung will die
zuständige Verbraucherschutzministerin
Steffi Lempke Regelungen für eine
bessere Transparenz beim zeitnah
prüfen vor genau zwei Monaten hat die
Terrororganisation Hamas Israel
überfallen und ein Massaker verübt
seitdem herrscht Krieg seitdem immer
wieder schwere Gefechte wie aktuell im
südlichen gazaastreifen auch Hanan Junis
wurde weiter angegriffen Israels Militär
meldet die Stadt sei eingekesselt man
habe mehrere Hamas Terroristen getötet
und Dutzende Terrorziele angegriffen
nach internationaler
an den humanitären folgen will Israel
die Einfuhr von mehr Treibstoff und mehr
Hilfslieferungen erlauben ja zwei Monate
nach dem Angriff der Hamas auf Israel
gibt es auch immer mehr Details zum
Vorgehen der Terroristen die Auswertung
des Überfalls die zeigt es wurde
offenbar systematisch sexuelle Gewalt
gegen Frauen und Mädchen angewendet
jetzt ermittelt auch die UNO Henriette
berichtet Bilder die soeherlich sind
dass wir nur ausgewählte zeigen können
Augenzeugen deren Erzählungen den
Schrecken erahnen
lassen die ganze Zeit die wir hier in
der Kuhle versteckt lagen haben wir
Mädchen gehört wir haben gehört wie die
Täter sich um die Frauen gestritten
haben ich hörte auch wie sie um die
Genugtung stritten wer wen zuerst
umbringt die jüdische Religion gebietet
eine rasche Beerdigung für genaue
Ermittlungsarbeit blieb kaum Zeit
Beweise für Vergewaltigung mit den
Opfern oft
begraben unsere Kriminalbeamten die sich
die Opfer ansahen während sie
Fingerabdrücke und DNA Aufnahmen sahen
das sie sahen Enthauptung Verstümmlung
sie sahen Schüsse sie sahen nahschüsse
und sie sahen die
Fesseln das schänden von Frauenkörpern
als Kriegswaffe eine junge Frau die als
Geisel genommen wird mit sichtbaren
Verletzungen die Last der Bilder
erdrückend doch
unzeigbar die Hamas Terroristen hatten
bodykameras bei sich die Sie vorbereitet
hatten und sie filmten alle ihre
Greueltaten die sie begingen sogar in
Echtzeit sie gingen soweit dies in die
Social Media Accounts ihrer Opfer zu
übertragen und posteten
alles
h Kriege haben viele Schlachtfelder und
werden allzu oft auch auf den Körpern
von Frauen
ausgetragen in diesen Tagen feiern die
Juden eines ihrer wichtigsten Feste das
Lichterfest hanuka an der Feier vor dem
Brandenburger Tor nahm zum ersten Mal
auch Bundeskanzler Scholz Teil das Fest
dauert
Tage Gläubigen treffen sich nach
Einbruch der Dunkelheit vor allem mit
mit der Familie und Freunden und zünden
die Lichter am hanukerleuchter
an mehr als vier Jahre ist es her dass
sich die Spitzenvertreter Chinas und der
EU persönlich trafen es gab also viel
aufzuarbeiten beim eu-chinaagipfel in
Peking laut EU kommissionspräsidentin
von derlin gab es eine Annäherung in
strittigen Handelsfragen auch das Thema
Taiwan und die Haltung Chinas im
ukrainekrieg wurden besprochen Chinas
Präsident Shi warnte die EU vor einem
Konfrontationskurs gegenüber seinem
Land und noch eine Annäherung in
unruhigen Zeiten Griechenland und die
Türkei lange Erzrivalen wollen ihre
Beziehungen offenbar verbessern seit
Jahrzehnten streiten die beiden
natoländer über Bodenschätze im
östlichen Mittelmeer und um die
Hoheitsrechte in der
gäis aber auch über die illegale
Migration ztausend Syrer und Afghanen
die kommen über die Türkei nach
Griechenland und dann in die EU und
nicht nur bei diesem Thema scheint sich
etwas zu bewegen mehr erfahren wir von
Annette
hilsenbeck es ist ein ungewohnt
freundlicher Handschlag den
Griechenlands Premierminister mitzotakis
und der türkische Präsident Erdogan
austauschen und das nach jahrelangen
Anfeindungen und Drohungen eine
Entspannung die im Februar begann als
Griechenland der Türkei beim Erdbeben
zur Hilfe
eilte wir wollen die
me des und der Kooperation verwandeln
als Türkei und Griechenland wollen wir
mit unseren Schritten ein Beispiel für
die ganze Welt
sein es geht um engere wirtschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit und um einen neuen Impuls
beim Thema
Migration in der Migrationsfrage haben
wir den entscheidenden Rückgang der
Migrationsströme in der letzten Zeit
festgestellt ich möchte hinzufügen auch
aufgrund der stark verbesserten
Kooperation der Polizei der Hafenpolizei
und der küstenwach beider Länder und
diese Zusammenarbeit kann und muss noch
weiter verbessert werden tatsächlich
drängt das Thema Migration wieder in den
letzten drei Jahren war zwar die Zahl
der bootsankünfte auf den griechischen
Inseln zurückgegangen doch seit dem
Sommer ist etwa auf Lesbos das
Übergangslager mit über 4000 Menschen
wieder voll und in der Bevölkerung
wächst der Widerstand dagegen erneut
eine große Zahl von Migranten zu
schultern die türkischgriechische
Kooperation soll nun den Schutz der
seegrenz
verstärken Präsident Erdogan wird von
einer solchen Vereinbarung profitieren
mitzotakis will die Türkei beim
EU-Beitritt unterstützen und sich für
eine erleichterte Visavergabe für Türken
stark
machen so jetzt sind wir beim Sport und
bei Christin Frust und Freude im DFB
Pokal und da waren es nur noch drei
Erstligisten ist wirklich eine neue
Dimension seit 20 Jahren und alle
Pokalgewinner der letzten 25 Jahre sind
schon raus darunter Borussia Dortmund
nach dem enttäuschenden 0 Z2 in
Stuttgart der BV entfernt sich immer
weiter vom eigenen Anspruch der VfB
bestätigt dagegen seine verheißungsvolle
Form während Stuttgart nach prächtiger
Leistung vom Pokalsieg träumen darf muss
Dortmund dringend etwas ändern so kannst
auf jeden Fall schweiter gehen wir sind
Dortmund da muss mehr kommen mehr als
ein Abseitstor diesen Schuss von sabizer
bringt der BVB nicht zustande ganz
anders das Team von Sebastian höes die
hochüberlegenen Stuttgarter mit
großartigem Pressing und filiganen
Kombinationen giras Führungstreffer in
der 54 Minute längst überfällig der
fairnesshalber sei erwähnt dass nicht
nur Marius Wolf verletzt ausschied
sondern auch mukoko sabizer und kurz vor
Abfiff auch noch riaason ob Dortmund
jedoch mit ihnen den 2:0 Siegtreffer
Stuttgarts durch Silas verhindert hätte
darf angesichts der mageren
Gesamtleistung des BVB durchaus
bezweifelt werden Stuttgart einfach klar
besser
ja vier Heimsiege am zweiten Achtelfinal
Abend alle Tore alle Spiele bei uns im
Internet auf ZDF heute und in der ZDF
heute App darunter auch die Erfolge des
ligaspitzenreiters Leverkusen und von
Herter BSC sowie der nächste Kuh des
Drittligisten aus Saarbrücken als
pokalschreck erst die Bayern jetzt
Frankfurt Saarbrücken hat wieder eine
Sensation geschafft ist wieder einen
Schritt weiter grandios einfach schönes
Erlebnis wieder gegen den Bundesligisten
gewonnen zu haben Frankfurt spielt kaum
Torchancen heraus drittligester Brücken
dagegen ist nicht zu bremsen wie in der
64 Minute Kai brünker trifft aus 11 met
keine Chance für Trapp in der 78 Minute
ist es an Luca Kerber der
reaktionsschnell den Sieg festzot das
2:0 die Entscheidung sbrücken damit im
Viertelfinale und der DFB hat nun
bestätigt klein Moment noch nia Künzer
wird ab 1 neue sportdirekt bei den
Direktoren bei den Frauen wie W die
Föller bei den Männer sorry fürs
unterbrechen danke schön Christin so ab
Mitternacht wird von Westen wieder
gefährlich glatt dazu und weitere
Aussichten gleich mit Katja horneffer ab
22 Uhr empfehle ich das heutejournal mit
Anne gellineck schönen Dank fürs
Interesse machen Sie sich gemütlich und
noch einen schönen
[Musik]
Abend
guten Abend westlich von Großbritannien
hat sich heute das Tief Udo
eingekringelt und das bringt Regen mit
wenn dieser Regen auf den gefrorenen
Boden fällt dann wird es spiegelglatt
das geht in der zweiten Nachthälfte los
und pünktlich zum Berufsverkehr sollten
Sie also mit Eisregen im emstand im
rheinminengebiet und im Schwarzwald
rechnen im Osten bekommen sie davon noch
nichts mit da ist es mal mehr mal
weniger stark bewökt auch mal klar oder
neblig die Temperaturen sinken zumeist
in den Rost am kältesten wird sie
Richtung kiemgau mit -11° im Westen
macht sie schon die etwas mildere Luft
bemerkbar mit + 1° am niederrein Schnee
Schneeregen und Glatteisregen ziehen
dann morgen im Laufe des Tages weiter
ostwärts und besonders gefährlich glatt
durch Eisregen wird es morgen
wahrscheinlich in Teilen von Hessen
Thüringen und Bayern im Westen fällt
dann nur noch Regen und weslich des
Rheins lässt der dann auch schon nach
und dort wird es mild da steigen die
Temperaturen morgen auf 6 bis 8° die
Frostluft hält sich noch in Ostbayern
bei -1 oder
-2° und in den nächsten Tagen geht es
wechselhaft windig und mild weiter am
Montag liegen die Höchsttemperaturen bei
6 bis 13° guten
Abend